皆さん
外国語しゃべりますか
また孫らの中には帰国子女でもそうでもない人もいると思うんですけど
特殊純子に対して
りほしゃべれるとか外国語しゃべれるって
聞いたり聞かれたりした経験ってないですか
私は中国から帰国してるけ
て中国語喋るのって
草に聞かれたことあるんですけど
全くしゃべれないです
虫の映画ペニーで時間の方が短いに英語の方が喋れます
そうで私は小学校2年生の8月から小学3年生がおりまでの五年間中国の陳たという町
に住んでいました
さて皆さん中国てどんなイメージありますか
治安が悪い
汚い
日本とあまり仲良くない
っていったらもう悪いイメージが多いと思うんですけど
学校1年3私も
全く同じようなイメージを持っていましたん
である日父親にきょうだい3人せずで座らせられで
大事なんだよ
お前だぞ5年間
中国で過ごすことになっ
って言われてそれを受けいただけて
きたくないなぁ
どっちかというと悪い加入が出てきたんですよね
なんでじゃー
悪い感情が沸いたかっていうともそやっぱり
中国に対する
マイナスのイメージだとか偏見また固定観念とかちゃんと持っててからなんですよね
てい
日本舌で
半の場所すらわからなかった場所にとっては中国なんて
地獄のような道で強い場所って
持っています
[音楽]
あらもう2011年の4月2日から
中国の陳だろうっていう海沿いの街での生活が始まりました
ん
人はいると思うんですけどジェントってもともとはドイツ領だったのね
都会の方に行けばそれなりに洋風の建物があったりとか
あとは
北京オリンピックのゆっと競技会場だったのねー
それが故に
有名な町でもあったんですよ
でも道路はすごい汚くて
ゴミとかまた食べようとガムが落ちてたりとか
車の風がすごく多かったので空気が悪かったりとかあとなんか中国人ってちょっと怒っ
たようにしゃべるんですよ
あーちょっと怖かったりとか
ね第一印象はほとんどイメージ通りでした
私たち日本人で中国に行けば圧倒的な郵送になれるんですよ
そこにいた日本人たちはまあ
東京で言うところの港区高層マンション
いわゆるオークションみたいな高級マンションも探知に住んでいます
私は正
とある高層マンションの23階のエメがビール部屋に住んでたんですよね
雨が見える絵がいい
えないと言っては皆さん綺麗な青い海を想像すると思うんですけど
まぁ実際私が毎日 b ていた海わー
もにまみれてっ
あみみエメラルドグリーンの海を
見渡すことができましたん
[音楽]
私は学校
には
そこにあった日本人学校に買ってたんですよね
が私4日本語を喋れない一番の理由です
だから少しはやっぱり現地の学校に行って中国を話せるようになっておけばよかったか
なと思うんですけど
まぁ実際は全く綺麗じゃないです
ああそれはやっぱり
まあこれまで自分が小中校と過ごしてきた学校生活の中で
中国電は学校生活がグー6点
話した楽しかったからなんですよ
やっぱり
に設備が整った校舎とか真斗亜
頭のクラスとか
いろんな都道府県中には全然違う国から来たーー
まあもちろん日本人なんですけど先生とかあと本当の夏とか
そういう
ことがあって
あと者人数ぬクラソフでん男女が隔たりがなく
彼も一緒にはさんだけとかなんと頭に一緒にしたりいうか
もちろんケンプともいっぱいしたんですけど
彼らはやっぱり今でも私にとってはかけがえがない
5無二の存在です
中国に住んで1年経ったときに
進んでいった高3魔女の
大家さんから
とに保育出て行ってくれって言われて
行く道
もちろんの団地の
でこんな高層マンションじゃないんですけどまあその中の何
1部屋2
引っ越すことになりました
1部屋自体は元々住んでいた23回に編よりかは全然広くて台所もすごい中立してい
たりとか
あとその例えばの1階には
ちょっとしたお店があってそこのぼさんとすごいな赤くなったりとかまた泊まりなかっ
たものに
建物の1階には
日本人が営んでいるパン屋さんがあって
を毎週水曜日に買って学校に持っていってます
環境的にもすごい
より良くなります mice 見て私よりも
面白いことにある日
その子供と住んでた部屋を道路から見上げてみたんですよね
そこには
入居者募集中ではもうこっちだって書かれてい
ハンデをよされたのかなって
未だにに主は買ってません
ねえ
まず中国に来て2年目に突入したときに
それまでに何回かやっぱり
一時帰国はしてたんですけどまぁ一時帰国して日本が中国に帰ってくるってなったとき
に
ほんと日本にいたいとか
ずっとこのまま日本で暮らしたいっ
て
うん妻来て逆に
15回て早く友達に会いたいな
帰ったら何食べようかなぁとか
いつのまにか
私の帰る場所
日本じゃなくて
16になってたんですよ
中国に住んでん
その中国の弁がとか
知り合った友達とか
週間とか
あとやっぱり源氏の人優しさん
主にたくさん触れて失点
は知らない間に私は中国のことが
大好きになってましたん
でもそれに気づけクマー
学校3年生の3月に入っ
地中から告げられた
とある
思いがけない言葉からでしたん
百田はフーガ3人制のビスおらすらるど
でもその時の父を植えば
なんかラテン系するっていうとけれどもっと深刻スマ
空9戻って
大事な話がある
帰国をすることになった
たんですよ
その頃の中国と日本の国際関係は
最悪でした
2012年の夏休み明けから
秋の終わりにかけて
半日でもかっ
各地である
頻繁に起こりました
だからん
私たち日本人は新登場
すごい日本人であることを
必死に隠しながら生きていきましたん
例えば
公共の場所はもちろん
ばとか
パク c の中でさえも
日本語を話しちゃいけないしあと日本人学校やっぱり
ハニーズでも激しくなんていくにズレていっ
一時休校することを決めたんですねそれはやっぱり
ランドセルをそっと日本勢の子ども達がどんな日がに何かも分からないし
日本人学校
まだ学校の校舎時代が反日デモ対象になりかねないって
学校はは
考えたからです
私たちの
火が入って
やっぱり
もちろん
学校うん一時休止つかもそうなんです一時9個とかもそうなんですけど
あと物理的な火が入ったら
日本のイオン系列の
スーパーであるジャスコが
破壊されて店内が
荒らされたりとか
あと
マーチン島ではないんですけどまだ全然違う場所では
日産の販売店が販売ての窓ガラスが笑いはられたり不可
なか中国国内は決して穏やかではなく日本人もすごい
行きづらい状況によって言ってましたん
やっぱりそんなことがあってから私は
だんだん
100人でやっぱり日本人の事嫌いなんだなっ
また
あるイメージというか
本当に進む前
持っていたイメージをにもよりひどい中国に対するマイナスの
感情を持つようになりました
ある日家族ちょっと買い物した後にタクシーで帰ることになったんですよね
やっぱりタクシーの中でもう日本を離すことができなくて
やっぱりをのされかねないという危険があった方です
家族は一言も話さずに社内はすごい
緊迫しています
はやっぱりそれに私の運転そうもなんか完全いたのか
なったたち
日本人の
k できたんですよ
お土産はやっぱり少し考えてい
ですね
白身の運転手は口を開けて
いいねっ
笑いながら言ったんですよ
びっくりしたいっ
超えてきたのか
ため息とか
稼いでもなくて
中国人独特の中国語な希
私の母国語である日本語でしたっ
オールされてもおかしくなかったしましょ
下されるぐらいだったらですねマシだなって思ってたんですけど
彼を
そんな言葉ナビはきっと知らなかったと思うんですけど
可愛いとか美しいとか
美味しいとか
いろんな日本語の単語
炎髪していきます
お父様
んでその2本
わかるんですかって聞いたんですよ
人からもらって
まぁ以前に日本人を乗せたことが何回もあってね
それに誰しも日本のことを好きだしっ
てくれたんですよ
が利いたときやっぱり自分の心の中のどこかで引っかかったん
僕に対する反日デモで寝る変えられてしまった
イメージが
も剥がれ落ちて
残ったのは者
な時間をかけてつけるやけどん
本当の中国のあり方でしたん
私たち日本人日本人だけじゃないんですけど
どこか海外で暮らすってなった時に
やっぱり
現地の人なし塗っては
ていけないんですよね生活をするのにも
食べ物を食べたりはこういった理
を探すなります
でこれまでに私たち日本人は
親族にいた珍田わけじゃないんですけどちょ
中国が現地の人に助けられてきたことをその時思い出しました
ん
私たちが何神であるかの前に
一人の人間としていっ
せしていてくれたことを
そのタクシーの運転手は
教えてくれません
そしてしばらくして
中国国内のとてもがそれ内容について
私たち日本人も
外で日本語を話せる行ったりとかあと
まあ
漫画0沿って学校に通えるように乗って
私はそのまま
中国田小学校4年生に上がろうとしていた時に入っ
さっきも言った
父親かな
こうするということ
告げられました
その年に帰ったまあ日本人はどうしても多かったです
自分が父親が何言ってなんか理解をして
涙が止まらなくて
いやだ
帰りたくないん
ずっと中国に住んでたいった
縋るように泣きじゃくります
さん宅に気付いたんです
私は
そしてちんだ
椅子のモニカ
豆乳好きになっていたんだな
そして私は
2013年4月3日に日本帰ってきました
ん
失ったものはすごく大きかったです
私が好きな本当に好きだったッ
友達とか先生とかと
同じ場所で同じ時間を過ごすことが二度とありません
今まで助けてくれていた
中国人現地の人に
俺を言うことができません
私私たちが住んで行った交差ファンション
ベッドの上で寝ることは
してないでしょ
減った分
それと同じくらいか
それよりもっ
大きい
青梅したそう
6人
本当のあり方を見れば
悪いイメージなんて変えられる
ということです
どんなに悪いうわぁさや
まあイメージがある国でも
言ってみれば
必ずに良い所が一つ見つけられるはずなんですよ
だからそのん日本で流れてくるニュースだとか噂とかでその国のことを判断するんじゃ
なくて
自分の目で
見て
体で感じてん
の国本当
を作り上げていく
いうことをする中世を私は
だからこそ
今恋し皆さんイギリスに留学してた時も
自分が日本にいた時に乗っん
as 命名時でイギリスを見るんじゃなくて時間をかけて作り上げたいの
いいですってどんな国なんだろうとか
文化持つ
[音楽]
本当の良いですのあり方を見ることができました
ん
同じ班
日本からの万有引力が働いているのか
海外にクラスっ
があったときに
予選して滝大変も
短い時間で帰ってくる事の方が
半日でもね中国語年入る予定だと2連打買ってくるとか
長いとねイギリスにいたのに
良い子さんの一年が入学する予定だったんですけど半年で帰ってくるとか
中央からいいに巡回日本以下てきた時に実家が思えるとか
8皆さん本当に火災保険も入った方がいいですよ
そんなこんなねやっぱり
中国に行ってその中でも引っ越しまして
半日でも日本に帰ってきて家が燃えてまた日本国内で引越しをしてまた実家に帰ってき
て
イギリスんで寮生活をしていて
なぜまだ2本目に買ってくる
はいに色んな場所を転々として切ってるんです
のしてきた経験があったからこそ
私は
中国でもなんだ事を活かし
どんな場所に行っても
ますてい
過ごせると思います
みなさんも今
持っている今悪いイメージを持っている国になったか
場所とか2
ちょっとっ
富士山は難しいと思うんですけどまた世界の
世界各国に行き来できる時が来たら
の国に行って
自分の目で見ていっ
自分の体で感じて
自分の心の中ねー
その国の本当
見てみるのは
いかがでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございましたん